one Soldier's Story in the war in
Ukraine following Russia's Invasion last
year scores of Ukrainian civilians
signed up to fight for their Nation many
of them taking up arms with little
training Holly Williams shares the story
of one man she met as he entered the
fight last year
maybe a lot of guys though we first met
private Andre Rogowski on a bus to the
front line a crane operator who'd signed
up just weeks after Russia's Invasion
[Music]
pure evil exactly
and then we stayed in touch and I very
proud that we liberate another Ukrainian
Village
for months he sent us videos from the
combat zone
including when he took a shrapnel wound
to his leg
in November we tracked private Rogowski
down in southern Ukraine how are you
just as friendly as before but now a
hardened fighter I saw
I saw combat
he took us to the small town of Visa
capilia which he helped recapture from
the Russians he seemed embarrassed by
the Gratitude of civilians
I want to bow to the Ukrainian soldiers
this elderly lady told us I'm proud to
see them I want to Free People it's not
right
they came and take a water not belongs
to them
in January told us he was heading to
buckmut the bloodiest Battlefield in
this vicious War when he got there he
sent us a message I am optimistic so
nothing everything will be all right I I
think
and then silence
rogalski had been killed in action
[Music]
buried with military honors
his mother received the flag that he
died for
in Ukraine's fight for survival its best
brightest and bravest a laying down
their lives
the last time I saw Andre Rogowski he
told me that he wanted to travel the
world and start his own business when
this war is finally over but now his
future like those of so many other
ukrainians has been snuffed out by
Vladimir Putin's Invasion Jeff
uh Holly even though he said he was
optimistic I'm sure Andrea appreciated
the danger did did he say anything to
you about how he wanted to be remembered
if something happened
Jeff you know um he didn't but before he
went to bakamuta when he was on route to
buckmouth this very deadly Battleground
I expressed to him how how worried I was
and he sent me a text message saying I'm
fearless I guess and I think like so
many other ukrainians he had decided to
look fear in the face and just laugh at
it and so perhaps that is how Andre
Rogowski would have liked to have been
remembered as someone who was Fearless
Holly we saw that personal connection
you had with Andre how many other
soldiers like him have you connected
with and perhaps lost touch with under
the same circumstances and is that
something in the back of your mind when
you meet each one of them
yeah Michelle we've met so many soldiers
and so many civilians over the last few
months in this country and we've stayed
in touch with a lot of them
um nearly everyone we meet here seems to
have lost something you know a family
member a friend their home their entire
city and the ukrainians that we talk to
say that that they believe that they're
fighting a righteous war that they're
fighting for Freedom that this is all
worth it but this the scale of their
grief and their loss
um it's just really hard to get your
head around
see it and you can hear it Holly
Williams and Keith thank you so much
Holly